that may have been my fault what the
hell Toby it was a classic I got a knock
knock joke no okay God Michael please
please please please please let me all
right knock now who's there KGB KGB we
asked the questions what the hell was
that what are you doing what are you
doing hey hey stop it stop it come on
what are you doing mine is part of a
hilarious joke mine was retribution what
are you doing no more knock knock jokes
that's it ding dong who's there
KGB do I get the door I'm not answering
the door no way it's the KGB I'm not
answering that yes you're going you
answer I'm not going to answer I'm not
going to answer it's the KGB the KGB
forit for no
[Music]
one it's true I am going to be in my
office if anybody needs
me wow sleeper hold B time for B
oh you are the weakest
link I'm friends with everybody in this
office we're all best friends we I love
everybody here but sometimes your best
friends start coming in to work late and
start having dentist appointments that
aren't dentist appointments and that is
when it's nice to let them know that you
could beat them up just hit me you'll
see I can't cuz I just got a manicure so
oh queer I queer ey that's a good show
important show go ahead do it just have
to I punch you oh yeah well that would
be kind of worthless because I know a
ton of 14-year-old girls are going to
kick his ass you know a ton of
14-year-old girls what belt are they
look Dwight is a wuss when we rented
Armageddon cried at the end of it
Michael I told you that was because it
was New Year's Eve and it started to
snow at exactly midnight Bruce Willis
they going to leave him on the asteroid
okay I'll punch you oh okay here we go
all right come on get
[__] okay email accounts so we're
starting with the account setup oh my
God is it in my eyeball yes I think he's
burning my eye Michael do something sack
up have to stop this L can I have that
no okay I am going to count down from
five five five four I'm not kidding 3 2
1 give okay all right
you you are going to learn to be more
professional Luke that's what you're
going to do
Luke what the hell was that I had to do
that this SC it all right are we
good you're
okay he's
okay after a clean strike to the chest
stomach or kidneys I will separate you
in a Bo a point first person of three
wins all right yes s lot of rules lot of
rules on the street we didn't have any
rules maybe one no kicks to the groin
home for
dinner what the hell was that no way
okay eat it all right that's the way you
want to do it Play Dirty huh okay game
on man sweep the leg Yeah I'm coming at
you
man okay purple Bel okay I got it no I
got his pants that was my pants no
points for
pants what you have no look no you're
something you're something God you look
like something an
idiot clean technique do that again do
that again I dare
you okay Bre Bre
oh you can't see you can't see one point
two points three
points I win I
win eight points n
points stop it no come on Michael open
your mouth no Michael
my it's okay guys I can handle this
everybody can go home we're here for the
show Michael you're just a bunch of
voyers are you eating popcorn it has
almost no calories you
ready
yes you have to keep your hands down I
know okay all
right no God Michael you have to put
your hands down put your hands in your
pocket
okay
pam
pam I'm really sorry I'm sorry what are
you sorry for so many things I don't
know it's hard to choose how about for
dating my mom maybe that's it and
dumping her on her birthday
yes okay
just don't ever date a member of my
family
again okay I
promise for the rest your mom came on to
me holy
crap are you okay no you're
okay feel better no you were
right wait why are you limping I don't
know let's get some raw meat on that
face I've got a chicken in the freezer
upstairs got you broken arm bo bo bo
broken nose boom boom boom broken
those going to flip you once a year
Dwight holds a seminar updating us on
the newest developments in the world of
karate because as we all know the one
thing the thousand-year-old martial arts
do all the time is change how can I pose
this to you in a relatable way you are
all members of the Yakuza and you happen
to be visiting the lacana trolley museum
and you are attacked by
Triads how can you hold them off until
your clan arrives you can't cannot go
wrong with a throat
punch okay so there's no defense for
that good to know no there is a defense
for that let me demonstrate someone
attack me Kevin go no way last time you
pulled my pants down and then you tried
to choke me with my shoelace false I did
choke you with your shoelace now come at
me okay with all due respect to everyone
here I think the most worthy opponent of
you is you that is correct unless there
happen to be measles present so let's
just say say that Dwight has come at you
with the throat punch now how would you
Dwight defend against it easy allow me
to demonstrate I am attacking myself
with a throat punch here it comes block
grasp wrist as such and what if he comes
at you with the other hand because he
does have two good point second throat
punch absorb the blow groin punch hip
block elbow to the gut uh-oh up to the
nose no you're not ah oh oh my God
he's making you look like such a fool he
really is but not for
long oh God inst oh not
again you let go you let go oh you're
right I can't hold on you two are so
evenly mashed I don't know how one of
you is going to get the upper hand the
important thing to remember Jim we
always have what is called the element
of
surprise now if you'll excuse me I have
a date with Destiny and from what I hear
she's
a help help oh gross don't lick my hand
God why is there so much saliva all I
had to do is think about pie and my
salivary glands did the rest gross what
what what God Jim a my appendix I'm
sorry my wound hasn't healed yet I'm
sorry oh man I'm so sorry I forgot are
you all right you
okay what are you doing I'm was trying
to go get up okay okay get up all right
I'm not going to let you buy then you
know what I'm going to just have to run
right through you
okay what are you doing are you really
revving up you know that doesn't work
Jackie CH seriously we're going to S
them back uh yeah that's the safest part
of a car in the event of a crash driver
always protects his side
first
back you sir no thank you I never let
anyone walk behind me seven out of 10
attacks are from the rear okay well that
still leaves a 30% chance that I'll
Attack you from the front uh yeah but
it'll be easier to stop I can always
block the blow or I can counter it with
it